j'ai 57 ans nous habitons avec mon
épouse depuis une trentaine d'années à
Rambouillet nous avons trois enfants et
je suis en activité professionnelle sur
Paris comme graphiste dans une agence de
communication ça veut dire que tous les
matins voilà il y a un temps de
transport pour aller au boulot et que je
mets à profit ce temps pour lire les
textes que la liturgie nous offre tous
les jours
et puis le soir quand il faut rentrer à
la maison j'ai l'habitude de me tenir
informé de ce qui se passe dans le monde
et dans les villes en lisant qui me
permet de ne pas être totalement
déconnecté car arriver à la maison pas
de télévision j'ai choisi de passer mes
soirées dans l'atelier dans une activité
de création picturale imprégnée par ma
foi
ça nécessite un temps de recentrement
c'est-à-dire pouvoir se rappeler ce qui
a été important dans la journée les
textes que j'ai lu le matin qui ont
maturé une rencontre tout ça sert à
enrichir le terreau sur lequel je vais
pouvoir essayer de construire quelque
chose je travaille sur papier au sol
totalement immergé dans l'oeuvre ça
demande un investissement fort et je
suis totalement immergé sur mon oeuvre
un jour ou à quatre pattes sur l'oeuvre
on y trouve parfois des traces de mon
pantalon
il faut
accéder à lâcher prise c'est à dire un
abandon en quelque sorte on va arriver à
un moment où il faut remonter les
manches il faut gâcher de la matière
comme tous les peintres vous le diront
et donc là il y a sûrement certaines
choses qui qui m'échappent mais c'était
un travail qui est très investi et qui
peut-être assez gestuelle elle est
d'autant plus importante et et habiter
qu'elle est toute imprégnée du laps de
temps de recentrement de prière si je
peux l'appeler comme ça que j'ai eu en
amont
j'ai toujours cherché à être acteur dans
l'église même modestement plutôt qu'être
consommateur d'église tout simplement
donc après des périodes de très jeunes
où j'étais enfant de coeur ou j'ai été
animateur liturgique et je le suis
encore aujourd'hui dans la paroisse de
Rambouillet
catéchiste également pendant une dizaine
d'années avec les enfants dans les
années 1990 il y a une espèce de de
croisement de route de croiser de chemin
et une espèce de révélation quelque
chose que je ne sais pas trop expliquer
mais où je me dis ben voilà tu as reçu
des talents tu es de formation
artistique et tu en as fait ton métier
c'est ce qui te permet de gagner ta
croûte et de faire vivre ta famille mais
ce qui te tient le plus à coeur c'est ce
cheminement de foi c'est cette recherche
de du Christ et bien est-ce que tu ne te
servirais pas justement de ces talents
qui t'ont été donnés pour pouvoir parler
de cette recherche parler de cette
lumière qui éclaire ta route les
premières années ont été des années de
traverser le désert parce que vous vous
retrouvez devant une feuille blanche et
puis quand vous dites ben voilà parle de
ton Dieu et parle de ta recherche vous
avez beau maîtrisé tous les moyens
d'expression
et bien vous vous trouvez devant un
drôle de challenge parce que comment
parler de quelque chose de si mystérieux
et d'aussi profond malgré une formation
artistique qui m'aurait permis et j'ai
commencé par travailler dans la
figuration
j'ai très rapidement
choisi de pouvoir m'exprimer dans
l'abstraction parce que je pense que ce
dont je veux parler est tellement
immense que il collait une image
figurative serait pour moi totalement
réducteur et ce que je souhaite en
priorité c'est laisser un espace
d'élévation de l'âme à chaque spectateur
le laisser libre de pouvoir cheminer de
pouvoir rentrer dans l'oeuvre avec ses
yeux et avec son cœur propre chacun va
faire un cheminement qui est différent
ça ne me dérange pas du tout
j'ai mis longtemps à pouvoir assumer ce
travail et à pouvoir le montrer mais
clairement cette œuvre a une vocation de
témoignage
c'est non seulement important de réussir
à produire cette œuvres cette tout aussi
important de pouvoir dans le cadre de
rencontre ou d'exposition de pouvoir en
parler de pouvoir
échanger de pouvoir donner des pistes de
lecture et de pouvoir faire naître
éventuellement c'était un sel qui va
ouvrir les cœurs
donc je suis dans ce très bel endroit du
palais du roi de Rome qui est un
monument historique du 18e qui dépend de
la mairie et des services culturels
le challenge c'était pouvoir montrer des
oeuvres ne pas décevoir des chrétiens
qui partagent notre foi parce que il y
avait une forte attente d'un autre côté
ne pas heurter la sensibilité de
certains laïques
qui sont très réfractaires aux choses
églises et d'essayer de faire un être
justement cette petite étincelle cette
aspiration cette élévation de l'âme
auprès d'un public qui serait rechercher
de sens son rêve d'avoir de piste et
sans avoir maître de mots sur cette
recherche de sens